airline boss Michael O'Leary flew into a
storm of protests the other day simply
for telling the truth
the Ryanair chief executive was talking
about airport security and suggested
checks on families need not be so
stringent quotes who were the Bombers
they're going to be single males
traveling on their own he said and added
if you're traveling with a family of
kids on you go the chances you're going
to blow them all up is zero so far so
what but when he went on quotes it will
generally be males of a Muslim
persuasion the predictable outcry
swiftly followed but why
while it's fatuous to believe all
Muslims come in the same color from New
York to nice and London to Tunisia the
tragic fact is the attacks were carried
out by criminal fanatics who
misrepresent their faith and use it as a
shield for their loathsome acts nothing
is achieved by ignoring that fact
solutions are only found when problems
are confronted surely his plain speaking
was simple common sense I just wondered
you know what the global population
Muslim population is nine billion
correct so are we saying half of that or
49 percent of that is under suspicion
should be racially profiled no no he's
not indicating that at all but I mean I
won't start quiz II if you look at the
point I made which is that sadly and I'm
gonna stress this point again people who
are completely opposed to the true faith
and they use Islam as a as a criminal
means to carry out their acts if you
look at that sadly there are these
people so you need a shorter you agree
they need the one they're the ones to be
screen well no I don't agree because
that is by definition racial profiling
and that that is discriminatory and it
would be illegal and I would add that
we're doing this in a context where
Muslims are constantly scapegoated and
attacked we live in a society where a
third of the population thinks that
Islam is a is a threat to British life
and we live in an environment where the
media is constantly demonizing Muslim
people your point
I just wonder because the police in the
UK are now saying that actually the
fastest growing threat from from
extremism from a very small base is do
you therefore logically do you therefore
think that the over 2 billion population
of Christians in the world should be
profiled in the same way because some
extremists abuse Christianity but I've
spoken enough I might return Michele
what nick says is you can't deny the
facts and if the fact is that previous
terror attacks on planes or whatever is
done by people pertaining to be Muslims
or they're Muslims mere Muslim meals
whatever that is actually in fact
there's not racist to stay at that fact
I think that where Michael O'Leary is a
bit silly is you know what does a Muslim
look like this is the Avenue because my
very best friend in the world is a
Muslim she looks more like Jessica
Rabbit than anything else in a million
years so just think it's very lazy to
suggest but if you look like that you've
got that haircut that skin colour off
you go to that line and also actually I
want everyone screened when they go on a
plane whether it's a pushchair
or a handbag or a brown pair some white
person I can't care less I want
everybody screened because that is how I
will feel safe because the next thing
you'll see is when you start
stereotyping right you'll not look like
that off you go to that queue then
people get wise to that and go well
actually rather than strapping these
bombs onto ourselves well strap them
over there to this push chair or this
kid or and if you start letting people
go through because in your mind they
look a different way than that's just a
recipe for disaster they give some of
the roles that you've served in racist
discriminatory language why are you well
just as a technical point it is entirely
justified to pick out a particular group
if you can demonstrate the likelihood
that they are going to
it is greater what unlawful is
unjustifiable discrimination so if
Michael O'Leary could demonstrate that
there is a greater probability of a
particular kind of person causing harm
and he's right on the right ground the
problem is is the one that Michelle's
just set out how do you know and Colleen
Mahmood who's smart Birmingham MP
actually has challenged him on exactly
this point how is Michael going to
identify who is a Muslim man a Muslim
man can be in African it can be agent it
could be say East Asian he could be
Eastern European it could be anybody if
you look on security services they have
robust methods in place they are doing a
lot of hard work behind the scenes to
make sure that this is done effectively
and with security in mind I think
actually that it's an interesting point
because in this country a majority of
Asian people are not Muslims actually
the two things do not sit together at
all you find against earlier for these
comments just briefly no I think what
Leary said is perfectly acceptable but
the way he said it was attention-seeking
and that she takes us away dealing with
the actual problem Rachel I read the
entire interview in The Times which was
a cracking interview and in fact I think
his remarks have been the burden of what
he says was not that you should spend
more time targeting Muslim single males
and I agree with you and you I mean the
book the woman who tried to blow up some
polls was born Michelle Ram stone in
Essex she didn't look like a Muslim
according to Michael is not a race it's
a religiously I think what Michael
O'Leary was trying to say was we're
spending a disproportionate amount of
time - yes it's doing security on old
ladies and Families from traveling with
multiple young children who are clearly
evidentially
not going to be terrorists since they
have done the X and here was basically
having a go at excessive security
everybody when there was no evidence
that they were suicide bombers and the
as a result of all this anyway
the number of terrorist hijacking
incidents since 9/11 has fallen by 60
want to come back I just wanted to bring
in Zainab Ghulam Ali from the Muslim
Council of Britain here's what she says
like this is the first time Michael
O'Leary has said outrageous things you
know this is a man who has formed in
this area and particularly in terms of
Islamophobia it's really concerning that
these views were on the front page of
The Times
obviously words have actions and in the
past when we've seen comments made by
prominent public individuals that other
Muslim people and we've seen a spike in
hate crime and I really hope that
doesn't happen this time but people need
to be very mindful of what they say and
the consequences of that might have see
part of the problem actually what she
said is not an exception but the Muslim
Council of Britain has been fighting for
the last couple of years to get a
definition of Islamophobia which defines
it as a kind of racism and actually
that's part of the problem that's why
Michael O'Leary can say this stuff
because they've now got it into the
public domain that Muslims are a race
they're trying to make Muslims into a
race and that's why Michael O'Leary can
get away with this Muslim is a kind of
anti-muslim racism what they've done is
created a framework in which Muslims
instead of being defined as they are a
pan racial global religion where all
sorts of people could be Muslims they've
now got it into the public mind and in
the mind of people like Michael O'Leary
that Muslims are a race there this is
they're doing actually not Michael only
I would say that anyone who's followed
this wouldn't would observe and the way
the Muslims and the anti-muslim
sentiments are circulating in our
conversation I would say people have an
understanding people have an
understanding of an islamaphobe 'ya as
targeting a racialized minority which is
what my which is what Muslims have
become all right
doors to manual you too while I tell you
what Ryanair have said no call for extra
checks on any group or persons was made
Michael was only calling for more
effective airport security checks which
would do away with much of the
unnecessary queues at airport security
day
for all passengers he apologizes
sincerely for any offence caused to any
group by the inaccurate headline in the
paper